Using SQLite makes it easy to delete,
update, and insert rows
using highly expressive queries.
One can even add new columns
as you revision your database.
It's not a surprise
that just about every popular app
makes some use of SQLite in Android.
It's a very popular and important component
of the Android solution.
Android also provides
a huge set of helper functions
to make working with databases easy,
including functions
to automate query building,
display ListViews populated by queries
and even compile statements.
For more information
about databases in Android,
see the Instructor Notes.
One thing that I wanted to mention
is that we're teaching you
the fundamentals
of how to build database
in a content provider on Android.
The idea is that once you are done
with this class,
you'll have a good understanding
of how it all works,
even if you end up using a library
to help build your database
and content provider
in your future applications.
That's it for a brief intro
into storage on Android.
If you want to learn more,
go to developer.android.com
and search on Data Storage.